hi what's your name Priscilla Boer you
like Elvis
Presley of course who
doesn't when are the kids listening to
these day Bobby Darren faan and
[Music]
you just what is the intent here Mr
Presley you got women throwing
themselves at you why my daughter well
SAR I happen to be very fond of your
daughter
she's much more mature than her age
21 22 that's
[Music]
22 you don't have to worry about
it black hair and more eye
makeup I don't know if I like
it what do you mean you don't know if
you're like
it he's not like you
imagined
you know there's a lot of rumors about
you was there something you're
hiding I don't have a goddamn thing to
[Music]
hide I need a woman who understands that
things like this might happen are you
going to be here or
[Music]
not
I want a life of my
own Angel Falls I give you
Christmas the lights are so pretty this
is
perfect what did you
eat
somebody please help me no please W
up Mar
Waters last Christmas still haunts
me it's time to let that go no one
cares everyone would be better off if I
was never
born did you see that did the power go
up oh my God
I stood under the Aurora and said
everyone would be better off if I never
existed well wish granted Angel strikes
every couple of weeks how can that be do
I know you it's winning you know that
okay this hurt hi hi I'm Henry Waters
you're safe now he's not going to get
you no one in this town knows me who are
you dad you weren't around to stop him
so he just kep going he likes
killing I'm here now let's have some
fun hey you hey Merry
[Music]
Christmas we got to stop him and get my
life
back you be safe
now
you just earned yourself a detention
Cent with you is already one big
detention son of
[Music]
a sir I don't understand that's
glaringly apparent I can't fail this
class oh don't sell yourself short Mr
coats I truly believe that you
can every year at Barton Academy
students faculty and staff depart the
campus for a 2 we winter break but there
are always an unfortunate few who have
nowhere to go for the holidays they're
known as the holdovers Mr Han hello Mary
I had you got stuck with babysitting
duty this year how'd you manage that you
know he used to be a student right yeah
that's why he knows how to inflict
maximum pain on
us I thought all the Nazis were hiding
in Argentina stifle it
Telly you just earned yourself a
detention sir being here with you is
already one big detention son of a
that's another detention you think I
want to be babysitting you no I was
praying your mother would pick up the
phone or your father would arrive in a
helicopter or a flying saucer take you
dead you don't tell a boy that's been
left behind at Christmas that nobody
wants him what's wrong with you there's
nobody here okay you stay out of my way
and I'll stay out of yours let
me most of the kids dislike you pretty
much hate you teachers too you know that
right I find the world a bitter and
complicated place and it seems to feel
the same way about me I think you and I
have this in
common I don't think I've ever had a
real family Christmas like this before
thank you Mary you're welcome history is
not simply the study of the past it is
an explanation of the present see when
you say it that way and throw in some
pornography it's a lot easier to
understand no matter what you
are I'd like to propose toast to my two
unlikely
companions are you trying to look down
my
shirt
no yes you're going to get me
fired this is your Rubicon do not cross
the
Rubicon the
holdovers
[Music]
Jesus
Carol danas prodigal child of the Milky
Way Nick Fury my favorite oneeyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there you know
cold no air
[Applause]
space Captain Marvel the
annihilator you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the
[Music]
favor what is happening to
me she's entangled our light based
Powers so we switch places whenever we
use
them strong Theory you can absorb
light I can see it and Cala who's Cala
hi she can turn light into physical
matter which I have never heard of I
could totally show you
[Music]
no around
make be
down first sty
profile
she's targeting every planet we call
home I would never choose to bring
anybody into this you are not the only
thing standing between this and the
universe oh my God we're a team if you
want
[Music]
go
higher
further
faster
[Music]
who's a good kitty
gos oh my
God I can't can you I got
[Music]
it Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the world
what are the Hunger Games for are
you are
you coming to the
Tre The Hunger Games they to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not
survivors
free we're
live smile it's why we have
teeth imagine it was your name that they
pulled it
strange I just want to know that
somebody still cared about me that I was
still of
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect people
and it's essential to accept what human
beings
are and what it takes to control
them let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people fueled with a te of becoming
prey see how quickly we become predators
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world the monsters all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people
mad
Mr snow let me ask you one final time
what are the Hunger Games
for
[Music]
H it's the things we love most that
destroy
us
n Go wins is a true story about the
worst soccer team in the world American
sore I can honestly say it's the worst
bunch of players I've ever come across
all I want is just one goal one
goal I went this not knowing anything
about soccer and by the end of the film
I knew
less it's a story about triumph over
adversity that's really the thing that
attracted me to this soccer's not in
their DNA they're weak they are not
weak jump jump stop you go
around this is the ultimate Feelgood
Underdog
film it's fun it's uplifting and it's
about
Hope we've worked too long and hard for
this are you with me my team coach my
ankle
is
I've got PL to be thankful
for my needs are small I buy them all at
the five 10 cent store oh I've got PL to
be thankful
[Music]
for I used to love this
town until what happened that
night tomorrow's Thanksgiving and I'm
tired of pretending like everything is
normal and it's not I want things to go
back to normal
too show some Enthusiast Thanksgiving is
an institution
here
[Applause]
no no no
no someone's up for revenge and they're
turning it into a sick holiday
game this is weird we're all tagged and
our names are at the table but why
[Music]
us
longer this goes the more Twisted it
gets every weapon he's using is straight
off a Thanksgiving table I don't want to
spend my life looking over my shoulder
we need to stop
[Applause]
him
[Music]
it is going to be a very Happy
Thanksgiving Let's
see we are going to make boy band
history tonight bro you're making baby
Branch nervous I feel like I'm going to
barf and pass out and pee your pants all
at once how' you know give it up for
[Music]
[Applause]
Roso you stop my exquisitely chiseled
rock hard abs and I quit Branch we're
out of sink we've gone from Boys to Men
and now there's only one direction for
us to go the back streets bye see you
later
Branch what oh hey are you all right
you're smiling and crying at the same
time it kind of looks like it's hurting
your face it does hurt my
face oh baby Branch I'm John Dory
Branch's brother what ow former brother
drama cor me
dinkle it's hard to say I'm sorry a
brother is a friend who can never leave
you it's the strongest bond in the world
I would kill to have a sibling to sing
with check out your old outfits puffy
jacket hcell necklaces denim tuxedos did
you have frosted tips look at you you
were so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic Branch our brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison there's only
one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner's
permit who was a Dy McMahon face the
better question is are you a
n who comes
there we're here looking for our
[Music]
brother oh my gosh
hello my name is Viva it is so fantastic
amazing to see other
tr did you just braid my hair you're
welcome it looks so good I love it is
your dad King Peppe uh yeah poppy I'm
your sister my what w hey man am I the
only one without a long lost sibling
this is your second chance with your
brothers
Branch b b maybe a smaller diaper if
this diaper was any smaller I could
taste it I know you think it's risky and
maybe it is but it'll be worth it
family's always worth it you're wrong I
ever I can't believe this is really
happening
need we still got it looks like your
Band-Aid aren't behind
you
just let me take you to a better
place I'm
going General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a clap R
Dr
I'm not built like other
[Music]
Menses move along now those in power
only see me as a Gro unfit for higher
office just like witches at black m but
I follow in the footsteps of Alexander
the Great and
Caesar evil minds PL destru if you look
down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you will always
want it Sorcerer of death
construction I must warn you I will not
Le a second in
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness
I found the crown of France in the
gutter and place it at top my own
[Music]
head as
you you want to be great but you are
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
were will all sleep again without This
[Music]
Vermin whose country are we
[Applause]
in
mine did you know there was a college
Christmas party tonight and I me and you
not
invited you all right yeah I've got a
flat tire take my bike hey that is so
kind thank you I'm sorry I don't know
your name I'm I'm Felix Oliver Oliver
Oliver I love you I love I love you all
right cheers
Olie my parents they've got problems
what kind of what do you me problems I
don't think I'll ever go home again well
why don't you come home with me come to
Sal B
Mr Quick wow and here he is now oh what
beautiful eyes oh how wonderful yeah I
told you it wasn't a minger oh but
darling you're kind about everyone you
can't be
trusted I had them hang up an old school
dinner jacket we dressed for dinner here
dressed for dinner yeah it's like was
like black
tie I think I like you even more than
last year's
one you're so um so what
real can't it being easy for Venicia
with you being a mother
why now it's time to take things up a
notch should had them Apple Bottom Jeans
boots with the
[Applause]
F this place
is you know it's not for
you lots of people get lost in
salurn oh that's just giving me
goosebumps look Pamela oh
no I think you're a
m quiet harmless drawn to shiny
things what have you talking
I just thought that maybe I could help
you're not leaving us you're not leaving
S I don't think I'll ever go home
[Music]
[Applause]
again 3 two one Asha I'm here I'm here
woo just one second let me catch my
breath Once Upon a Time stood Rosas the
most Magical Kingdom founded by a king
with the power to grant wishes you are
their handsomest most beloved King
you're right I am a handsome king I'm so
nervous I think I'm going to explode my
best friend the king's Apprentice my
mouth trooping I feel like it's
trooping Asha come with me the wish
wishes of Rosas wow people give their
wishes to me and I grant the wishes I am
sure are good for Rosas some of these
will never be granted not some most they
deserve more than I decide what everyone
deserves so I look up at the stars to
guide me I wish and throw CAU to every
sign oh you sp booil us with your magic
I didn't do it
what last night I made a wish on a star
ah and the star
answered I'm talking I am talking who
knew my voice would be this low I
believe I have just been threatened who
would dare threaten
you I have no resp response to that so I
look there is a traitor amongst us find
Asha it's a dead end with unsanded
mahogany oh good find Valentino my butt
found
it I started this I have to finish
it so I make this wish what are you
hiding nothing is to be and nobody what
is going on in there okay ladies your
wings can't fly but your voices
can do you want to see what the world is
really like
yes my name is Emma Stone I'm playing
Bella Baxter in the film four
things this is Bella she's n better
she's understanding what it is to be a
member of society good evening the more
autonomous she becomes the more
challenged these men seem to be by it
it's a very very funny
film why do people not just do this all
the
[Music]
time we must experience everything Bella
this makes us
home
Bella I wanted to play Bella because it
felt like acceptance of what it is to be
a woman to be free to be scared and
Brave Bella why I keep it in my mouth if
it is
revolting I must go punch that
baby how did you come to write this book
what really struck me was that too few
books were about my people where are our
stories
where's our representation would you
give us the pleasure of reading an
excerpt yo Shir girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you Monk your books are good but they're
not popular editors they want a black
book they have a black book I'm black
and it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they published look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses
it I be standing outside in the night
dead beat dads rappers crack you said
you wanted black stuff that's black
right I see what you're
doing we sold your book
no we believe Mr Lee has written a
bestseller there a joke the most
lucrative joke you've ever told now is
stag a pseudonym yeah Mr Lee can't use
his real name is this based on your
actual
life yeah you think some ass
college boy can come up with that
no no no I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that not me they ran
300,000 copies your books Che change
people's lives they're offering $4
million for moving rights yes the Dumber
I behave the Richer I
get is this has gone too far stag arly
is still on the run from authorities you
haven't done anything it's not like they
can arrest
you wish I could go back to not selling
books is it bad to cater to people's
taste people want to love you Monk you
should let them love all of you there's
already so much Buzz because of the
movie deal Michael Beach Jordan is
circling we want to put him on the cover
in one of those um scarves I guess you
would call them tied around his head a
doag dag that's it doag and a tank top
with the muscles showing something
called the fire
[Music]
department we're thinking we can get it
out in time for J
[Music]
te
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
OA Lumpa an Oompa what now in fact in
Lumpa land I am regarded as something of
a Whopper they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed
T inventor may I present Willy Walker's
wild and wonderful wishy-washy Wakka
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
o he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor
he doesn't like it when people say poor
send Wonka a message do not sell
chocolate in this town you're going to
get more than a bonk on the head I love
a bonk on the head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
bullies give them the old one
to I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course
run
away every good thing in this world
started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world
I'm not in premium
EC light some I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
[Music]
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke you quite
viciously with a cocktail
[Music]
stick I hate the way that I love
you and I need
you
[Music]
I let's just tell everyone we're
together
what could be kind of
fun there's no way we can convince
anyone we actually like each
other trust me we're at a wedding A
Million Miles Away From Home who knows
what could
[Music]
[Applause]
happen convincing enough I hate the way
that
I love you
[Music]
4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way I don't know how you did it pops my
job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of
Atlantis half a billion people from
every known species in the sea call this
place
home but that doesn't mean they all like
[Applause]
me I'm going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds
dear I'm going to murder his
family and burn his kingdom to
Ash he must be stopped for a global
meltdown is
imminent I think I know someone might go
to help
us you look
rough good job little brother High fire
do not call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate his job true
king built Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges we need to find Manta he's
different now he's stronger than
before it's the black
Trident during King alin's time there
were Seven
Kingdoms the Trident was a curse upon
them
all start magic is
spreading he means to end the
[Music]
bloodline I don't know what lies ahead
but we can't leave our children a world
without
hope you're not as bad at this as you
think if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
[Music]
follow
hello hi so you're looking at me from
the
[Music]
street I'm assuming you're not with
anyone never see you with anyone
[Music]
this moment
da
yeah they died just before I was
12 I'm trying to write about them at the
moment how's it
going
strangely
hi
hi is this real
does it feel
real our boys back home our
son look at you you were just a boy and
now you're
not it was a long time ago yeah I don't
think that
matters
[Music]
treat I've always felt like a stranger
in my own
[Music]
family scared or
something always running away do you
[Music]
remember sorry I never came in your room
when you were
crying it's funny doesn't take
much to make you feel the way you felt
back there
[Music]
again you think he'd like to be with
them i' always fall
along this is a new
feeling you and
me
[Music]
together into the
world
Wing
deployment
Elin here we
[Music]
go this isn't about
migration it's about
Adventure is that a little scary sure
you need a
hug can you let go now you feel better
no then it hasn't kicked in
yet there's a whole world we've been
missing out
on things we didn't even know
existed what is that do laange let's
stuck a
laange it's you with larange on
top
[Applause]
ever since I was a child people said my
family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing could
ever hurt
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please
David Carrie I want you to join your
brothers in the ring yes sir I love that
now we all know Carrie is my favorite
then Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change what do you
want in life Kevin B more ribs I want to
be with my
family you know be with my
brothers what do you like to do with
your
brothers Harry and
[Music]
David
together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that were passed down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron claw to
you so what do you think like we're a
lot I love your family
K you going to be an uncle yes sir oh
man that makes me so happy
I talk to you about something tomor
Dad's too tough on us you got to say
something baby that's what your brothers
are for you feel that you feel that
that's
pressure you're pushing too hard I'm
fine K seriously I'm just
sick going scared man get all my head of
control was a terrible accident I should
have stopped him I need to think about
my family your job is to wrestle live up
to that deal or we are
through I told you to look out for him I
just love being out there with you guys
it's the only thing that matters to me
the will forever be the greatest family
in the history of
[Applause]
[Music]
wrest
two objects cannot occupy the same point
in
space at the same moment in
time the corner races at
you you have perhaps a crisis of
identity am I
Sportsman or a compe
if you get into one of my
[Music]
cars you get in the
win
[Music]
slow and
so you're going
broke how you spend more than you
make so what do I do win the Mia
or you are out of
business this is a gun pointed at our
head you should assign me control of
your
stock I have to have all the cards in my
hand will have the cards are in my
hand all of us are
Racers it's so deadly
passion our terrible no wonder will need
me back how can I stay
W if Italy is looking for a
scapegoat then here I
am you were supposed to save him you
promised me he wouldn't die the father
deluded
[Applause]
himself
two objects cannot occupy the same point
in
space at the same moment in
time
so go beat the hell out of
[Music]
them how come you don't laugh
n ain't you got something to make you
just
[Music]
smile my sister and I ain't seen her in
years you know if you ain't going to
laugh you need to sell your footy
[Music]
bone I was married to a man I didn't
love whatever I say
[Music]
go and he took my sister away from me
even if we have to part you and me us
have one
heart how come you so nice don't know
maybe you too
nice you seem like trouble I come here
out of
respect but if there ain't nothing to
get and sure ain't none
again
[Music]
now I got your
attention what you need to hear drinks
on the house push the
button there going to be some changes
made you got to stand
up I know my sister somewhere in the
world someday we're going to meet again
keep your head held high just like mom
taught us it's time I'll be free from
you and then turn to Creation I died
before I let that happen good that's
just a gway present I've been
needing baby baby
baby
what are you got to do time for you to
see the world P the
button oh sweet and loving
[Music]
God
com